put no effort into it whatsoever like
they are advertising to the audience we
do not care about this this is stupid
we put no effort into this
here you go and the audience goes oh gee
i can't wait to watch
media is very excited the entertainment
media very excited today because it's
it's been announced there's a marvel has
a new show coming out uh she-hulk
and so this is kind of like the feminist
female hulk and it's getting rave
reactions in the media the trailer just
came out i want to play a little bit of
the trailer by the way this is real this
is not like a parody or something this
is not a babylon bee thing this is an
actual show that they're putting
together they're going to put out their
she-hulk let's uh let's watch a little
bit of this
i just want to be a normal anonymous
lawyer can you tell us where she-hulk is
jen you're a story now
girl your ass looks crazy right
[Music]
now could be an avenger oh i'm not a
superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
[Music]
is there anything more depressing than
dating in your 30s
yeah this is the best date i've had in a
while oh should we split some fries
let's get those to go
if you have not seen the movie idiocracy
uh you really should see it's the most
prophetic film possibly
in the history of cinema and we are
living that that every that that right
there is like a fake it's like a fake
film that you would see in the film
idiocracy
that's what that is
and
but people will watch it you know you
know something else i watch these
trailers i don't watch any of the actual
uh shows or marvel movies
because i'm an adult number one
uh and i have self-respect
but when i see the trailers
one of the things that really jumps out
of me is uh on top of just how stupid it
all is and all the wokeness and
everything now we got the female
feminist hulk who's literally sweeping
men off their feet and everything
but also this is it just me or has the
cgi the computer graphics are worse
like if if i didn't know any better and
you showed me that trailer and you said
that that was a show from 1992 i would
believe you based on how it looks
so is this just my imagination or have
the special effects somehow gotten worse
in fact you can i might not believe that
it was from the 90s because it doesn't
look good enough to be in the 90s
the special effects in the 90s were
better
go back and watch the original jurassic
park
that the special effects of that movie
are still kind of stunning because it's
better than anything you see in movies
today
so that's the one thing at least we know
that um
that
uh very rarely are are good films made
in hollywood anymore it's just nothing
but garbage
and so you expect that you expect a lot
of you know you expect the story to be
terrible uh maybe expect bad acting bad
scriptwriting and everything else but
the one thing you would expect is that
at least the special effects should be
really
amazing by now
okay because the progress of history
there's it's it's not going to lead to
better storytelling
with the trajectory that we're on right
now but it should lead as technology
improves you think at least the special
effects will get better and they haven't
and i think part of that is it's just
pure laziness on the part of the studios
they realize that they don't need to put
any effort really into the special
effects because they can just shovel
this garbage out and people will eat it
why put
it does it takes more time costs more
money to have good special effects why
bother
they just put anything out and slap the
marvel label on it and a bunch of morons
will just go watch it it doesn't matter
put no effort into it whatsoever like
they're advertising to the audience we
do not care about this this is stupid
we put no effort into this
here you go and the audience goes oh gee
i can't wait to watch
meanwhile they're ignoring the aliens
it makes it all the worse
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated